in terms of going back to what you said
about knowing your genre and how i think
it was nancy at innovative said oh yeah
i've got this great pirate guy and to
not be that you know jack of all trades
master of none how did you know that
dark comedies were for you how did you
try on many different genres and then
realize that i think it really
goes back to what you're inspired by
and i'm inspired by
um
you know filmmakers like wes anderson
i'm inspired by charlie kaufman i'm
inspired by
um alexander payne you know i'm very
inspired by ryan johnson i'm inspired by
original concepts and original story
lines and um
you know telling a great story so i
think that
uh for me based on the people that
inspire me also michelle gondry and
spike jones
these are people
especially wes anderson who i can only
be so lucky but sometimes people tend to
compare
some of the things that i've written to
what he's writing
i just relate to that i i think i have a
little bit more of an ironic
look at life you know i think i tend to
find sarcasm
to be very fascinating and interesting
so i tend to be able to write that
dialogue and that story and that humor
better than
than other genres and like i said i'm
not against exploring other genres and
if people want to write in every genre
they should i wouldn't discourage them
but that takes a lot of work and a lot
of research and you know if i were to
write something that i'm not familiar
with if it was a detective piece or a
film noir or a science fiction i'd study
as much as i could about that genre so
that i know that i'm following the basic
rules of telling a story
in that way
but um
you know i think
for me my strengths lie in
drama and dark comedy and so that's
where i've kind of stuck
and i'm continually learning new things
about the genre on a daily basis so i
enjoy it
and
you know most of what i do most of what
i write actually could probably take
place on a stage you know it's a lot of
character-driven
plot lines with a lot of dialogue and
talking heads you know it's limited
locations that's primarily why i fall
into the category of independent
filmmaking
is because
these are films that can be done that
don't have to have astronomical budgets
so
it's not that i won't
reach out of the genres that i work in
now at some point but i'm very
comfortable and i enjoy these genres
actually the television show that i'm
executive producing i was created by two
people um eric tegenhoff and rob tepper
and
we are all hoping that we can be a part
of the writing process of this you know
we're shopping into network so
ultimately they'll make the decision of
who's gonna write the pilot
they'll make the decision of who's going
to write on the tv show who will be
staff writers
but we're all hoping that we get that
opportunity and this is more of a very
dark
psychological thriller style drama so i
know that i'll have to branch out of my
comfort zone of a dark comedy or just a
you know broad drama um to to reach a
point where i'm writing something that's
compelling in that capacity and i'm
excited to do it and i've been
researching from the moment that i
thought i might have the opportunity to
do it so i think if you're wanting to
write in different genres just know what
you're writing
and and go back to the people that
inspire you or the films that you like